transgender councilwoman benny brioli
has received more than 20 death threats
since she was elected two years ago
she was forced to leave brazil for
safety reasons
and only returned after being promised
special protection
that did not happen
i have no security only a bodyguard
brioli still fears for her life but has
decided to run for rio de janeiro's
state legislature in october's elections
these elections are not only about
ideals and votes they're also a
challenge to remain alive we've seen
people being killed because they're on
one side or the other the political
polarization is very strong
brazil has a history of political
violence but since 2018 when the last
presidential elections were held there
are growing concerns that verbal and
written death threats may be actually
carried out in july a supporter of
president jay bolsonaro shot down
marcelo hoda a member of the leftist
workers party founded by former
president luiz inacio lula da silva
lola is bolsonaro's main rival in
october's presidential election and is
heading the polls
valdez ferrace who is running for
congress and is a close friend of
bolsonaro says all candidates are taking
security measures seriously
he remembers the day bolsonaro was
stabbed during the 2018 campaign
[Music]
bolsonaro is wearing a bulletproof vest
but that's not enough he will always
ignore protocol to talk to the people
the same year bolsonaro was stabbed and
elected councilwoman marieli franco an
activist of black and gay rights was
executed the crime was never solved but
a statue in her name has been
inaugurated
during the past three years political
violence in brazil has tripled
brazilian politics has always been
polarized but since 2018 we've had
president jair bolsonaro openly
disseminating hatred no other president
has done this that's led to an increase
in political violence
brazil's federal police has been
training an extra 300 agents to protect
candidates during october's elections
but men in brazil fear it's not enough
money cannot give al jazeera rio de
janeiro